and Inc on this unit here with Jack and
Luke unbelievable a lot fought it free
from Lin who is barking at the referee
as he heads out for a new stick Jack
Hugh swooping in sharp angle SC this
game is [Music] [Applause] [Music]
TI I've just made mention of the fact that
the Devils have to make a concered effort to
shoot the puck on this power play and
they certainly do that haircuts Jack
Hughes High stepping backs off mider below
the goal line goalies close your side door
and if you don't the elite players like
Jack Hughes will take advantage of that
daylight as he did there what a play
by Jack Hughes 1-1 at the credential
Center saw goals like that a handful of times
in the postseason absolutely last year around
the NH and to Emily's credit she had mentioned
earlier how Jack Hugh was looking at the iPad
several times to see if he could correct
anything and he certainly did and he's on
the board as a result it's a her point and
your point specifically about the power play
that's right got to be a student of the game
folks you have to be a student of your craft
and the Hughes Brothers have certainly been that
and a nice adjustment by the devils and they're
able to get the equalizer here Jack Hughes
who had 43 goals last season he's got his
first for the devils in the new year so we are
tied at one inside of six to go in the second